welcome back to the channel guys today
pretty light casual video okay because
we're spending time
upgrading the set around here i don't
know if you noticed that's a new camera
right there
hey you can see see more of my face i
don't know if that's a good thing or a
bad thing
we're upgrading the studio okay i just
want you guys to know that
we're spending millions of dollars on
production value
for you i mean look here's a sneak peek
of my new house don't tell anybody here
oh hey sorry that's my realtor
sorry apologize uh but yeah we're gonna
be you know
going into that new production space
very soon very exciting
in the meantime i want to get you some
of these videos out here you know in
case
you need some content you need some
laughs so what i want to bring to you
today
is something pretty amazing i saw
recently from the coffeezilla arby which
has just been going bananas lately
uh thank you i don't really say that
enough but
thank you things have been just going
amazing on the channel lately we're like
150 000 members strong
but even some of you go above and beyond
you don't just
subscribe and smash like like anna anka
asks you to
some of you go out and you create entire
webtoons
have you guys seen this this is
absolutely insane
look at this madman this guy
here i'll have to find him on twitter
real quick this guy
makoto just created
a brand new webtoon called the internet
guru chronicles which is guaranteed to
be
the biggest webtoon of the year
obviously and let me say
i asked him if i could share some of it
with you guys on the channel
because obviously it's his artwork and i
just i just want to
show you some of it uh and he said yes
he said absolutely so today that's what
we're going to be doing we're just going
to be going through this guy's
awesome you know webtoon just checking
it out and
just seeing how it is let's just put
some tunes on here and let's
let's go through this thing shall we you
know what i mean
i got like the sound board now guys i
can control it all
for my fingertips right now see we're
upgrading that's what i'm talking about
so anyway check it out first of all
quality this is a high q you could just
tell right away
high quality i wonder where they got
that image from that is a
straight dan lok call out
look at that dude it is a straight like
i love this reference look at that dude
unbelievable already i love this guy
right imagine if you could change your
life for the better
wealth status
oh there's something that webtoons
capture like there's like a
i don't know an emotional thing this
iconic style
gets that you really can't capture
anything else status
freedom life's good isn't it what are
you willing to sacrifice to reach your
goals
all right hey you yeah you
don't skip this ad incidentally you
probably saw a guy
exactly like this before this video just
a side note are you living an
unfulfilling life do you hate your 9 to
5 job
do you want to be financially free like
me
i'm hosting a free seminar in nyc to
give you the shortcut to success
and the first 100 to sign up will be
able to attend for free
free this is not a scam it's always a
scam
the free event is always a scam or at
least i should say it's always just a
gigantic sales pitch you know what i
mean
okay and now introducing the ceo
of snake oil group john
madoff man he's really hitting a lot of
references in here
he's just like straight up like these
guys are bernie madoff ponzi games i
think that's what he's saying
thank you thank you thank you for coming
out tonight i'd like to start out with a
question
why are you here raise your hand if
you're tired of being broke
oh look at this poor guy he probably got
invited by these two idiots look schmuck
that's who that's who invited this guy
guaranteed 100
you calling that poor guy
huh me why aren't you raising your hand
high enough
um i uh you see that's the sign of a
weak mindset
oh god this guy nails it this guy's
absolutely
crushing it right now this is exactly
what these guys do
how do you expect to be successful if
you can't even raise your hand with
confidence
if you're not willing to make the effort
then you are
hopeless gosh dude i want to just make
that my logo from now that's such a
funny face
this guy's really good with like
character emotions and their faces
i like it you know i wasn't always this
rich
i used to be just like you sitting in
the chair attending multiple seminars
to get to where i am today i had to
develop the correct mindset
i had five failed business attempts
five if i had a negative mindset i
wouldn't be standing here today
but with my positive mindset
my big brain positive mindset
i became successful and if you want to
be successful
oh here we go by the way you guys know
what this is right this is a clear
reference to uh
the story bridge that these guys are
always selling right where they go
i was once just like you but then i
figured out after
many failed attempts i used to be a
loser just like you but after i
found out the secret oh then i became
the brilliant success that i am today
able to rent lamborghinis and if you
want to be able to do that
take my course that's what it always is
that's the story bridge you're willing
to buy if you think that they've been
where you are that's like one of their
psychological
tactics this was me 10 years ago i was
working a dead-end job
with 69 969 credit card debt
living in my mother's basement and this
is me five years ago
after telling my boss to f off i started
three successful businesses
after generating more than four million
dollars a year
oh man and with the correct mindset i
was able to develop
high income skill dude if there was ever
a doubt that he's talking who he's
talking about there
that's like the dan lok special right
there say it with me
high income skills it took me nine years
to develop these
high income skills and after closing the
10 million
deal i thought why don't i share these
skills with the world
so i wrote a book called high income
skills with a high
income mindset oh dude i'm sick of high
income
it's like if i never heard the word or
phrase high income again i'd be so happy
which by the way is a nigerian prince
times bestseller don't you mean amazon
bestseller
uh and i've coached over 45 000 people
around the world through my master class
snake oil salesman
and today you'll hear from my two best
students
script now give a big and warm welcome
to
elaine here let's give a big warm
welcome
let's come on sound board
hello um um my name is uh
elaine the fact one of you guys took the
time to actually make this
it's super high quality got all the
references from the channel
is so insane and by the way they said
that like
coffeezilla this was the inspiration for
the whole thing this is
incredible i've never really had that
much fan art done
with the channel i think i've only had
like one or two things and uh to see
something of this quality
this scale done it's mind-blowing and uh
if you guys want to be entertained
i'm sure that this is going to spin off
into a bunch of cool directions so i'm
excited to see
what the guy has planned because it's
kind of just started so
uh how is everyone doing tonight
uh god dude
this guy's a legend with these faces
i i was a college student majoring in
barista studies with uh forty dollars no
forty five thousand 000 in student loans
but when i met bernie i mean john
made off my life changed for the better
um is she reading off her palm
yeah john taught me a high income skills
and i was able to develop a high income
mindset and i
uh was uh able to use my eye income
skills to get high
income clients and and and
okay give her a round of applause it
kicks her off the stage oh man dude
that's basically it that's actually one
away from i think the most up-to-date
episode right now
and uh yeah i want to give you guys
something to go watch i don't want to
end this in you to think that we've
completely caught you up to what's
currently going on there
so i'll link the i'll link it in the
description uh the link to this webtoon
if you want to go check it out if you
want to go check just support
coffeezilla fan spinoffs
this is just incredible and super
well done i think you guys can already
tell but
yeah man i'm flattered tozu makoto dude
absolutely hilarious uh looking forward
to see
where you take this and uh
yeah all the best that's all for now i
just wanted to show you guys that i was
pretty amused i thought you guys would
be too
so enjoy it go check it out uh and don't
forget
to smash like and subscribe thank you
[Music]
lean on us
[Music]